thank you alejandro yes i'm here with uh
leveronian
after finishing his tournament in a very
peaceful way
yesterday you teased me that you're
going to go for it and try to catch the
leader
what happened how did you reach that
decision to just make a quick draw today
oh yeah i considered my odds
i thought you know most likely
maxim is going to be playing peacefully
too because
he's having a bad tournament so
when i play for a win i normally play
with taking a lot of risk so i thought
okay if i lose uh if i have to play for
three results then it's just
from mathematical point the gain
is less than than the loss
you've finished quite strong the
tournament two and a half out of three
that must feel good
what does it mean for you to play here
in bucharest i know you have kind of a
history with the town
yes absolutely generally the whole
region
of romania moldova you know elmira
knows uh we
came here and in the 90s
with my family and i think
if not for hospitality of elmira's
family
generally and the tournaments in
romania i i don't think i would
progress so much so this has a special
place in my heart
i believe one of the organizers of all
times
mr pesci he invited you to quite a few
tournaments
absolutely he was a lovely person and i
also played some of the longest games i
ever played
i think the longest game i played in my
life was against
briachna yes again
i think it was maybe eight hours i was
little child for me
it was endless game
you have so many fans around the world
uh what can they expect from you
in the next few months what's next for
you okay i
uh i think it took me long to
get in shape in this tournament
uh but now i feel that i mean i have
some control
i finally calculate things and see
things
so you know
i just look forward to be playing chess
again and i really love
that we get to travel we get to uh
see each other and we play tennis with
fabi so things are
uh looking great are you going to play
in paris or you're not going to paris on
this one
no no we're going to paris i don't know
if we're going to play
uh tennis there but we we're planning to
play tomorrow
we're we're definitely going to play
some chess in paris that's for sure
love always a pleasure to have you here
in the studio my pleasure
guys back to you